paul yuri was captured by russian-backed
forces nearly three months ago in
eastern ukraine his family say the aid
worker had gone there to help
but russian separatists accused him of
being a mercenary today his captors
reported he'd died in detention in the
self-proclaimed donnex people's republic
this is my worst nightmare
um
as i said
on the posts and the public you can look
at them
i hate the russians i hate the
government i hate them all
it took him once and they took him again
mr yuri's captors say he died five days
ago from complications with diabetes and
a heart condition medical issues his
family confirmed
the uk foreign office says it has
summoned the russian ambassador to
respond to what's happened
but today mr yuri's daughters told sky
news they just want to be able to mourn
their father properly
we're
we're trying to get the body to come to
us so we can give them a send-off
but at the moment they just keep saying
they'll try
we want to give them a funeral
we want a proper goodbye that we didn't
get and if we don't get the body back
um it's going to be even more upsetting
because we don't know what will happen
to it
or if it goes to someone else we'll
never know
mr yuri was described as simply trying
to help ukrainian people his family here
now want answers as to whether he got
the medical treatment he needed whilst
awaiting trial
catering photography sky news